we expressed satisfaction with the
progress we have achieved in our common
work to implement our partnership
priorities we focused on different areas
of cooperation where we see concrete
results are coming from our partnership
in particular regional security
stability and counterterrorism we also
discussed the situation in Syria in
particular the follow-up of the Brussels
three conference we had last March
let me obviously mention the important
work that Jordan is doing doing to host
Syrian refugees also here the European
Union stands by Jordan in particular by
the hosting local communities that have
all our support I just want to say on
the bilateral level that we are
extremely proud in Jordan of this solid
partnership that we've had with the with
the EU it's a partnership that has been
ongoing and growing for years we had a
very good conversation of regional
issues this process palestinian-israeli
conflict was key there is no alternative
to the two-state solution the lack of
political horizon over the past few
years has been extremely frustrating has
been extremely dangerous and we need all
of us to work together to try and offer
hope that this conflict will be resolved
on bases that will ensure that the peace
is lasting I will consider Jordan in
this region to be a bank of stability
and as far as possible peace and this is
only so they achievable and sustainable
if we support Jordan wherever possible
in particular in its economic
development having in mind all the
challenges Jordan faces amongst others
the refugee crisis where you have done a
great job to host so many refugees and
to provide
with him many job opportunities